joe biden is facing what could be the
first major diplomatic crisis of his
presidency
moscow has recalled its ambassador to
the u.s for consultations after biden
confirmed he thought
russian president putin was a killer the
u.s president was speaking in an
interview with abc news
he also promised to hold vladimir putin
accountable for meddling in the u.s
elections
director of national titles this was the
interview that galvanized two huge
nations the u.s and russia
when in an exclusive interview with abc
news george stephanopoulos asked
president joe biden
so you know vladimir putin you think
he's a killer mm-hmm
i do so what price must he pay the price
he's going to pay well you'll see
shortly
the interview comes as the united states
is thought to be preparing new sanctions
against russia for its meddling in the
election
at an earlier meeting biden made a
pointed remark to putin
you said you know he doesn't have a soul
i did say that to him yes
and to end his response was we
understand one another
i wasn't being a wise guy i was alone
with him in his office that's how it
came about it was when
president bush had said i've looked in
his eyes and saw his soul
i said look in your eyes and i don't
think you have a soul and looked back at
me said we understand each other
it's unclear what kind of a response
moscow will have
but no doubt u.s russia relations have
seldom been this low
let's bring in our correspondence
following this story for us we have
emily sherwin in moscow and william
gluecroft here in berlin it's good to
see you both
emily let's start with you there in
moscow joe biden said he considers putin
to be a killer
what exactly is he referring to
well joe biden didn't make it very clear
what exactly he was referring to but it
is clear that over
putin's time in office there have been
uh
a whole list of prominent killings of
kremlin critics or at least
attempted assassinations for example
there's the opposition or the critical
journalist anna paritkovsky who was
killed in 2006.
there was the opposition politician
baris nemtsov who was killed in 2015.
there's the attempted assassination and
poisoning of sergey
skripal in 2018 and last year
the attempted poisoning of opposition
politician alexey navalny as well
now putin's critics have always squarely
blamed him for those killings or at
least his system
of course putin himself has always
denied any ties with uh these killings
and with other killings
um and uh of course investigations as
well have never
linked any of those murders or attempted
murders
to vladimir putin himself okay william
let's talk about this u.s intelligence
report that
essentially blames moscow for meddling
in the u.s elections
to what extent does it say that russia
actually tried to sway the vote
moscow and other countries as well but
when it comes to russia the report
basically outlines
a campaign of misinformation a campaign
of
influence peddling placing misleading
or outright lies into news media into
social media
accounts influential people on social
media
right-wing media also peddling favors
with many trump associates the report
doesn't actually outline or specify at
least the declassified version
doesn't specify any specific examples or
names but one of the biggest
examples being pointed to is trump's
lawyer rudy giuliani meeting with
ukrainian
lawmaker andre derek who has since been
sanctioned by the u.s and has been
accused of basically being an agent of
the russian state
helping put these kind of ideas these
anti-biden ideas a lot of
a lot of these lies we've heard or
misleading facts about
uh biden's and biden's family's role in
ukraine and corruption allegations none
of which have
and have been any evidence has been
found to that effect but putting those
kinds of ideas those kinds of stories
out there into the u.s media and social
media to cause confusion
to stir up trouble we saw that in 2016.
one major difference was in 2016 it
appeared that russia also tried to
actually hack
election infrastructure and that was not
the case in 2020 they maintained they
maintained more of a
influence and social media and
misinformation campaign
so emily we know that the kremlin has
broadly rejected accusations of election
interference but have they addressed any
of the
specific allegations in this report
no there was a pretty standard denial
that we heard from the kremlin
spokesperson dimitri piskov yesterday
he called that report wrong baseless
and unsubstantiated and basically
questioned
the quality of the claims in the report
but i think the really big news here in
russia isn't so much the report that's
sort of seen as
the usual accusations that are leveled
um
at the kremlin and at russia um that the
kremlin has denied over the years
the real news here is this statement
about putin being
a killer one parliamentarian today
said that that is really a red line that
the u.s
has now crossed and the next step would
only be for
russia and the u.s to break diplomatic
ties you have to understand that this is
essentially a personal insult that
has been leveled um at the russian
president in the country where even
putin's critics usually kind of make
broad claims or
broad criticisms against the kremlin or
against the government instead of
touching the president himself
yeah president joe biden certainly
talking tough there william just quickly
if you can
he says that there will be consequences
for russia what exactly are we talking
about here
he was very vague as we heard in that
report partly because he doesn't want to
probably tip his national security hand
but also there's
rather limited room that biden and the
united states can
can maneuver for punishing russia
sanctions are usually the go-to
a tool we there's many sanctions against
russia and russian individuals with
varying effects it's quite easy for many
russians especially wealthy russians
well-connected russians to
evade those sanctions but u.s officials
are probably also going to look at other
kinds of financial tools
russian money sloshing around in western
financial institutions that they can
maybe go after
and of course building alliances keeping
united front with the eu
with nato to present a united front with
russia that would make it harder for
russia to
enact this kind of divide and conquer
campaign that we've seen over the last
several years
chipping away at u.s allies especially
in eastern europe
our correspondents william gluckhoff
here in berlin emily sherwin
in moscow thank you both very much